انهكت جلسات الغسل المحدده باربع مرات
اسبوعيا حسن بهبهاني اذ يقضي جل وقته على
هذا الجهاز بواقع خمس ساعات للجلسه
الواحده
منذ اكثر من سنتين ينتظر حسن دوره على
قائمه طويله لزراعه الكلى في الكويت
للتخلص من معاناه الغسل النفسيه والجسديه
متعب جدا الغسيل يعني ممكن يسبب هبوط
بالضغط فجاه ارتفاع احيانا فجاه يلعب
بالسكر يلعب بالنفسيه
معنويا كل شيء يعني للاسف ان احنا نفتقد
ثقافه التبرع بالكويت يعني هذا اجر وصدقه
حقه جاريه يعني عنده قد ينقذ الانسان من
الموت لن تنتهي معاناه الغسل سوى بوجود
متبرع يقول الكويتي بو ربيع بعد ثلاثه
اسابيع من اجراء عمليه زرع كوريا جدا
يستمع الى تطمينات وارشادات طبيبه المختص
لضمان تقبله الكليه المزروعه من متبرع
متوفن
يغسل ثلاث مرات بالاسبوع
كان يؤثر علي ياخذ من وقتي اوكي قله
الحيله الحركه ما في الاكل ما في
الحكه بالجسم بسبب ارتفاع الفسفور بالجسم
تعاني الكويت من شحن في الاعضاء بسبب قله
المتبرعين اذ ان اقل من نصف في المئه من
سكانها يحملون بطاقه تبرع وهي البطاقه
التي يوافق الشخص من خلالها على وهب
اعضائه لمحتاجين بعد وفاته
واقع دفع هذه الجمعيه المنوطه بها حفظ
سجلات المتبرعين الى اطلاق حمله اعطي
الحياه لنشر ثقافه التبرع الهدف من هذه
الحمله هو مضاعفه عدد حاملي بطاقات التبرع
بالاعضاء بعد الوفاه فاحنا حاليا عندنا
تقريبا
17 الف مسجل للتبرع بالاعضاء بعد الوفاه
هذا الرقم مقارنه بعدد السكان يعتبر رقم
قليل
مبدئيا لمضاعفه العدد الى 30 الف
تعد بطاقه التبرع بالاعضاء هذه وصيه غير
ملزمه في الكويت فتنفيذ رغبه صاحبها بعد
الوفاه يتطلب موافقه اقارب الدرجه الاولى
وهو ما يحتاج الى تعزيز ثقافه التبرع في
المجتمع مع قدره كل متوفى دماغيا على
انقاذ حياه ما يصل الى ثمانيه اشخاص
الجزيره الكويت